[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today we have a very special guest
not just a special guest a very special
guest
returning to star talk we have william
shatner the one and only a beloved
actor
portrayed captain kirk on the starship
enterprise in the original star trek
series and movies that followed it
some years later
and
he's of special interest right now
because he was on board the suborbital
flight of blue origin's new shepard
space capsule this is a 10-minute
journey where you go across the carmen
line that's the line where you enter
space
and he was the oldest person to ever do
this at age 90. and let's get straight
into this
so william shatner can i call you bill
yes if i can call you neal
please please
by all means so you you start out life
as wanting to be an actor yeah is that
well i mean i must have emerged from my
mother's womb not knowing what to do
okay by the time i was given time and
food and nourishment even though exactly
uh after suckling a bit i thought
i should be like i was about six years
of age when when i and i was in a camp
play and
as the legend goes and
i made people laugh and cry and i
thought wow that's wonderful
and i've never done anything else
so i i was channel surfing one night and
i stumbled on you
in a bit role in the movie
judgment at nuremberg you were like a
court clerk
or a court caster according to some
people right
no but it's true i sat there the whole
movie at that legal table
watching these incredible
luminaries from the screen pass by and
do a day's work and then
leave and come back it was it was an
extraordinary
uh experience for a young
actor and and there i am binging because
at
on on classic in all the old episodes of
the twilight zone and you're
in two episodes
you've got a double credit
yeah separate distinct episodes yeah and
they and they are among the most popular
strangely the reason for that i don't
know uh perhaps uh your sagacity you
would be able to analyze
why those two shows have remained in the
top
13 uh uh every time they play uh
a group of them i i don't understand the
popularity but it must have something to
do with touching
uh some core of humanity of
something well you play you play a
slightly crazy person in each one just
only slightly just enough where you can
the viewer can relate to your anxieties
being anxious about something like in in
one case uh uh flying we're always
anxious about flying
and uh
and the other one was about getting your
fortune told and you we're always
worried about what the future holds and
what why did i say that uh for something
in the past so we're always concerned
about those two subjects
yeah so for that reason i think as you
correctly deduced it reached into us as
viewers in a way that while you were a
slightly extreme version of it we felt
enough of ourselves in your character to
relate to it more deeply than i think
other characters portrayed or written
for so i want to make sure that your
your acting chops are out there up front
because
to to
take this ramp
into
space initially of course with
star trek ultimately doing it for real
did you have any space influences when
you were a kid you were already fully
grown up during the apollo era
credit that
space wasn't mentioned uh
you know all those years ago
there was the sun there was the moon
and people were
running around trying to figure out how
they hung in the sky i was
after
i was after galileo
you did okay
i i i
you and galileo weren't tight you
weren't tight
like that we were like that actually
but
no
there wasn't anything about nothing
about space and nothing i was always
interested in football and and and um
and i was acting in montreal
doing um amateur um
uh theatricals and and i somehow
i don't know
what it was i think there's something in
my genetic makeup that allowed me to be
in an intuitive actor i've never studied
i don't know how you studied to be an
actor but there are styles and i just
fell into
those styles i may have seen them in
movies maybe i was imitating them but
there is
a a regality to shakespeare there is a
there's a effetence to 18th century uh
19th century uh
comedy
there are styles that you sort of
acquire
the way you
speak the way you move your hands your
feet i never studied it but somehow i
knew it and i don't know how well so
what's happening then is the
the world you know we enter the cold war
there's an arms race and there's also
the birth of a space race
and there's a poignant part of
shatner in space which is just
now posting on amazon prime
if you have a video subscription there i
think it's it's quote free the uh in
that program there's a there's a
poignant moment where the star trek
series which went three seasons
all right uh you know just barely longer
than gilligan's island whatever okay and
and
so
and it ends you're out of a job
you you and your wife divorce
and there you were putting a vision of
space into our hearts and minds and now
that's gone yet
you witness neil armstrong taking first
steps on the moon could you just tell us
about what you were feeling in that
moment the contrast of these two yeah
yeah well
um
i
i was
i got a divorce just as the show was
canceled
and
i don't know whether you know this or
not neil but divorces are very expensive
okay
so there i was i had this divorce i was
now broke
and i
and and i was coming off a series which
in those days meant that
uh the people who
hire
think oh well he's known for that and we
won't uh
hire him for this because he's known for
that that sort of thinking went on for a
while
and i was in that thinking so it was
difficult for me to find a really good
acting job
and uh
and so
i decided i would do summer stock
and the summer stock is out on the east
coast uh on the uh
cape cod and
so i
i don't remember whether i bought a
truck or whether i had an old truck and
i put a cab on the back of that pickup
truck
and it had a shower and a bed and i had
a dog i've always had a dog a doberman
pincher so there was a book out in those
years called travel with charlie
i remember that yeah john
i did travels with charlie only my dog i
i don't remember his name but a regal
marvelous uh male doberman sat beside me
and i drove across country
and uh put together a a
a a play and um
and and did summer stock and part of
that summer stock
goes
on to long island and the hamptons but
just to be clear just to be clear you
were homeless at this point
and your home was on weekends back of a
truck
yeah there your home was on wheels if a
guy sleeps in his car is he homeless or
has he got a debbie i live
my address is chevy
wait that's back when cars were big
enough you could sleep full out flat out
on the on the right on the bench exactly
right so the philosophical question is
are you homeless if you're in something
you own in your car you're not sleeping
on the streets
so i i had a little uh
tiny house here which i didn't pay for
um
so i slept in the back of this truck
in this case you said you also you ended
up from cape cod into the hamptons is
that right i'm in cape cod and i park
in a pasture
uh
and i'm living there and i and i go and
i drive over to the theater uh a mile or
so away and perform at night and then
that night i'd drive to the pasture and
park and sleep in the cab so it was this
evening that i was
sitting
in a chair in the cab in the cab
or lying down in the chair and i'm
looking through the window at the moon
and i've got a little black and white
tv set
and i'm tuned in to
uh armstrong on the moon
and i had been at the cape the year
before
and had
some wonderful exchanges i i laid down
in the in the limb i looked around i uh
i i the
the astronauts took me around they gave
me a ship of the uh a model of the
enterprise and i signed it i'll see you
on the moon and it was i was like i was
like a junior astronaut
uh and everyone's okay thank you very
much and they laughed and
and
then i left and a year later i'm looking
at armstrong
putting his foot on the moon and
we had discovered or either then or a
little bit later that as our ratings in
star trek went up
uh the government voted more money for
nasa
uh that became more popular we
popularized star trek popularized
uh space travel
and so
in some and so i felt in some tiny
minuscule way
i had a little something to do with that
and there he puts and and the world is
watching and i'm lying
bereft
money moneyless homeless in my chevy uh
looking at him go on the moon and i and
the irony
of that
incredible moment
and my destitution
struck me even then and upon retelling
i'm able to make it even more dramatic
[Laughter]
but your hand gestures helped on that
one right so here's
so so bill here's my analysis i think
what happens is once we're going to the
moon
we don't need you
right because all of a sudden
space exploration is real it's no longer
pretend and then
three years later only three years 1969
boots on the moon 1972
no longer boots on the moon we stopped
going into space and here's my analysis
i think we all say to ourselves
wait a minute that's not wait wait a
minute this is supposed to keep going
and it didn't
it didn't even the film 2001 of space
odyssey 1968 that was imagining 2001.
wait a minute this all stopped well what
do we have left
we got to go back to start star trek
star trek was that hope and and and so
your popularity grew
in reruns
bigger than it ever was during the show
much bigger star trek took off in reruns
and in reruns and into the 70s later
after we stopped going to the moon so
you
you dude became our only hope at that
point
you were betting the wrong horse
you had your money on the wrong guy
so i think
i think
that
the fact that we became more distant
from space
made star trek that much more
important and relevant to us
that's my how do you what do you think
of that well i think it's it's beautiful
and i hardly agree with you that uh i
alone uh brought the uh
nasa
re redid itself because of me no
um
[Music]
what happened is
uh
the expense of going to the moon
kennedy's saying we shall go we're going
to go to the moon in
in a decade and american pride
made us do it once we had done it it was
like oh god we know we know we're not
going to spend any more money on that we
got you know we got politicians pockets
to line and all the money is gone
uh
so they
because of the expense
and i don't know what happened
but it was like the air went out of
american
determination in space
uh we lost it for a while
um you know
um
i don't know whether this is apocryphal
or not but my understanding is yuri
gagarin
and for your audience to remind them he
was the russian astronaut who who
made it the first uh
launch into uh space came down like a
stone and a parachute but
he was up there for a brief moment and
apparently
he said
it's blue
and then
parachuted down
now
we see the sky as blue and we say oh
that's blue but but knowledgeable people
know that's refraction of the sun the
air is colorless
but whatever it is the the the water
the moisture in the air gives us the
blue color and and and so
we think okay well but it's colorless
just blue because of the refraction of
the sun
he gets above it
and he says ah
it's blue
and i thought when i heard that story i
thought what a glorious moment when the
first human being
looks down upon our planet and says it's
blue and what a color
i mean blue is a beautiful color it's so
engaging it's so
calming i mean you paint a room blue
because you want the co the color to to
to be
restful
air force one is paint it's painted blue
in part for that reason it's a very
calming color i have gone across this
continent
many times uncountable times in every
manner
possible when i was a kid i thumbed
across the united states i left montreal
got to san diego went to vancouver got
to chicago back to montreal on my thumb
i've motorcycled across the continent
i've driven a truck i've driven i've
been a sports car i've been with the
family i've been alone i mean
it's endless neil
the continent is endless the roads go
disappear into infinity and you think
i'm gonna oh my lord i have to go and
then you get to that infinite point of
infinity and it goes even further it's
it's not
it's then by rising above
it and looking down oh my god
it's minute
the earth is minute
and only then do you begin to get a
a sense of the
of the
of the relationship
of this little rock
to the vastness of space ego
that's it's crazy we got to take our
first break but when we return more of
my conversation
with the inimitable
or occasionally imitable
william shatner
we're back with william shatner are you
ever thinking while your starship
captain that you'll ever actually be
the high up above earth and you see the
blue planet that's fantasy the whole
thing was fantastic sometimes we'd laugh
about how fantastical we were on stage
27 at paramount studios pretending to be
we're in space and we move the rocks
around now we're on a planet and we
shoot this gun and later they put a
little
uh light thing in and and and it's all
fantasy it's all beautiful fantasy about
human beings somewhere in the future but
so you know it's these crazy guys who
were thinking futuristically
never thought i'm gonna go up there
well just to be clear star trek wasn't
at least for me and i think for
practically anyone who observed it was
not
just space fantasy there was space
movies and space you know there was lost
in space was a tv show but that didn't
somehow get deep within our soul
uh star trek had
messages within it yeah it had more
there were morality
the surroundings were fanciful
but the meanings the reason it's popular
i think is just what you're saying that
it dealt with human beings but i meant
the surroundings were fanciful if you're
talking about racism and a guy is half
black on the right and half white on the
left he meets a guy who's half black on
the left and half white on the right you
know who are you how do we we're
fighting and we're because you're
different from me and so the
the stupidity
the
nonsensical stupidity of racism is
evident by this by these two guys who
are fighting over the fact that one's
different from the other uh slightly
it becomes but the value of telling a
space tale is you get to present that to
people
without
them being confronted in their
behavior they have to sort of
internalize it and then realize it for
themselves rather than think about put a
pie in their face
exactly think of how that would work the
guy's like oh geez what's he complaining
about it's got the black here and the
white here in the morning
some guy who
who may be
prejudiced in any way is say laughing at
the stupidity of this guy yes you know
and he doesn't realize he's laughing at
the stupidity of racism until later in
the way if he's you know if at some
point in time
yeah listen black white was a different
so
that was the the beauty of star trek
yeah yeah and it so it was it meant more
than just
a
tale told in space and and and by the
way just
if i can um fanboy a little bit here
anytime i'm asked okay kirk or picard
[ __ ] this
you know this is like they they quiz you
that when you enter comic-con right kirk
i'm kirk all the time and let me tell
you why because
your character
actually not i'm a very non-violent
person let me start with that but let me
just say your character would fight the
bad guys
if you see your captain actually getting
into a fist fight oh my gosh
they're invested in this they care
about what is true and righteous on a
level where they're putting their own
lives at risk you fought the gorn
you did not some pawn that you sent out
to do so and so i thought that level of
bravery for a captain i greatly
valued and my
favorite line
my favorite line and i'd forgive me the
star trek fans for not knowing the exact
details you're on the brit your
character is on the bridge
your shields don't work anymore the
enemy vessel is out front
and
you
execute some command that's mysterious
on a channel that's already been uh
decoded
and
and spock says uh captain this is no
time for a game of chess
and that command was a self-destruct
command that would also destroy the
enemy ship captain there's no time for a
game of chess and you said no spock
it's poker and it's yes that's what
that's my captain
oh my gosh i've totally forgotten that
totally
great can you imagine the wonderful
writer who wrote that thing he got
anti-best line ever especially because
because spock you said you know spock is
right here and then you say no you are
more right because you know you're
bluffing and they don't know it oh my
gosh so so you got
i'm on the team captain kirk the whole
way
so so now you get tapped by jeff bezos
and and
well
about two years before that uh about
three years now uh jason irwin a friend
of mine who was a producer uh on another
series i did said you know you should go
up in the middle no no i'm not going to
go up there they don't want who cares
and i don't want to jeopardize that he
says but it'd be good no no no anyway
the idea suggested they say come up to
seattle we fly up to seattle i beat jeff
the the whole lobby of uh of amazon is
all star trek we sit down at the table
uh shatner up in space that sounds good
we'll let you know and we go back then
kovid hits and nothing happens then we
hear that
jeff bezos is going to go up in space
himself so we think well maybe he'll
choose shatner no he chooses his brother
and an and a lady with gray hair and a
boy and they go up and i said
that's well that's interesting well
maybe they'd like you to go on the
second but no i don't want to go up
second for god's sake that's the vice
president we want the president
so then they asked me to go up on the
second one uh though no i'm not going so
i turned it down
but then i in my uh
you might have a an explanation for it
the wonderful moment between sleep and
week when you're lying there thinking
you know and your brain is going and
you've got all kinds of wonderful ideas
which you forget when you get up uh i'm
thinking you know
going up to space it's an experience i
should i should try and experience that
as fearful as it sounds i'm so i agree
to do it
thinking
it's innocuous i'll just go up
come down who cares and i've had that
experience
who knew
that that would be as uh as newsworthy
as it was i didn't i thought it would be
uh
unknown
well let me just say that
you can't just send up any famous actor
and have the same reaction as sending
you there's no
question about this so in in the shatner
in space documentary
um he's got all this footage in
anticipation of you going into space and
some really fun encounter with you and
your wife and daughters where you
announce to them
that
and they say dad are you going to die we
don't want to lose a dad on this and
um
and of course if you die you'd go out
completely in flames
but in space and a glorious ending it
would be rather than lose your teeth
slowly
one by one you lose them
you're right yeah no i'm not
[Laughter]
so
so and of course no there's no reason
to have pre-footage
of just any random famous person who's
about to go suborbital it's not
interesting we need someone with space
legacy who who who sat at the fulcrum of
people's hopes and dreams of space and
that was you so i'm delighted that that
such a documentary could be made with
that footage and and we see we see this
side of you i mean i was delighted by
that i was worried
because you guys had to walk up to the
capsule up all those damn steps wait a
minute shall we pick or something to
carry you up
dude you're 90 years old
i'm telling you they asked me to come a
day early it's hysterical that you
should come upon that point so what do i
i'll go there and then
maybe mr bezos will be there and i have
a chance to talk to him and uh and and
he wasn't and and and so where there's
and here's where this
and there's the gantry let's go
see what the gantry okay let's go and
see what they can do now let's walk up
the gantry oh okay
eleven flights eleven flights and four
thousand
altitudes then i'm going up and i'm
going
but i made it and i now looking back
i've got to assume somebody said to
jesus
do you think he'll make it up the gantry
he's 90 years old
let's check him out
i don't know if that was a checkout
imagine if i had failed what would they
do oh sorry
you've only made me yeah yeah we lost
shatner on the on the
step
oh lord i'm telling you that was i when
i look back on that i i have to laugh
what if i hadn't made it
and thank you
i was walking up and there'd be like
seven people behind me you know bring up
they're 20 years old hey let's go and i
go yeah where you going
i used to be able to scramble up neil
you may not believe it i used to be able
to run up a little flight now i'm trying
to walk
leaving you like can you open a bottle
top as easily as you did before
uh no but i
take kindly the council of the years
which is gracefully surrendering the
things of youth so do you handle mine
from well do you know what it's my son
you mind opening the bottle for me
would you mind getting the lease up this
bag up of the upper when they're flying
okay i need some help because the up
and the bag is heavy
no i i think no no i've got tools i've
got tools now i got tools i'm i'm i'm
good with that uh but there's some shots
of you inside the capsule before and
during and after and there's one of them
when you're weightless i don't mind i'm
gonna tell you
you look like you were about to barf
just the your facial expression so
you you don't have to divulge that out
here thinking about it i
i wasn't grieving
you know and you know that vomit cometh
they they they fly yeah you know the
outside loop that they get yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i've heard the airplane
so now
there's nothing worse than zero g vomit
okay because it doesn't it doesn't just
fall now all your attention is trying to
avoid it
oh here comes one straight at you
and all your attention is dodging the
barf
[Laughter]
so tell me so um for me if whatever i
would miss most i think if i never get
to experience this is the feeling of
weightlessness so can you describe that
no i can't because um
because uh
there aren't words uh in the english
language weightlessness is a new thing
there aren't words
to describe weightlessness oh you're
weightless and lift your arm well you
can't you can't uh yeah
the whole rehearsal part the practice
part was getting in and out of that seat
in weightlessness but of course you're
not weightless so you have no idea of
how to get into that seat and tie
yourself in and because you're going to
hit seven g's
so weightlessness like suddenly i'm
floating but i don't want to float
i want to get to that window and see
and see whatever it is i'm going to see
and and there's footage
of jeff
bezos in the first flight he's
weightless and his ass is towards the
camera and this kid
and this kid is throwing skittles
at his ass
that's the first moment of
weightlessness and i thought
[Laughter]
that's what i it just depends how big
your ass is right
so i it's indescribable you're
weightless but it's not like being in
water which they practice the astronauts
practice it's like nothing it's
indescribable
it's like
floating if you imagine yourself
floating
but your body's not accustomed to not
feeling gravity so it's like what well
and you're startled you're like what is
the sensation
and and everybody's had things to plan
like we'll we'll lift our hand up and
then and in the first flight they had
hello mother or something or i had
nothing i didn't i wanted to
oh my lord and it was awkward like you
didn't know what to do now if you spent
time just in weightlessness
like they have that
updraft of um
of air oh yeah i know you're talking
about yeah the um the
uh the skydiving uh uh
right exactly so you you they can
practice in a in a chamber
that's approaching it i guess
but here
it's it's
it it's like
it's like being
ill with an illness you not don't know i
don't know whether it's feverish or or
you know something that you
how am i feeling what am i what am i
it's the complete
unknown
of weightlessness that occupies you to
begin with it's like startling like holy
cats what is that
combined with in my case i want to get
to that window
i don't want to waste any time being
weightless i want to see
the earth or throwing skittles you're
not going to throw a skin you're not
you're not going to burn weightless time
throwing skittles at anyone's ex
you have two minutes of weightlessness
two minutes in that in that orbit in
that
moment momentum
i wanted to make use of it
by looking by absorbing
having a sensation
seeing something that very few people
have seen we've got to take another
break the second of only two breaks in
this conversation uh when we return more
of my conversation
with william shatner
we're back with star talks conversation
with william shatner are you a different
person for having done this
neil i'm sure that when we talked last a
few years ago i must have expressed
myself in in in terms of ecology cause
i've been an amateur ecologist for the
longest time rachel carson wrote a book
called the silent spring
and i read that 50 years ago and i
thought my goodness if that's what's
going to be and then i have a great
friend um michael tobias do you know
that name the ecologist i do know the
name yes i do i don't know
documentaries well he's a friend of mine
and we we did a series called uh voice
of the planet many many years ago we
went all over the place even up into the
himalayas uh looking at places that were
being degraded as a result of and this
was years ago this is more than 20 years
ago
i saw from my own eyes what what what
we're doing including ocean
stuff i
i uh
so you were early in this
year early out of the box i was
preaching this years and years to
the scoffing
of reporters oh look at this actor
thinking he's a
scholar of you know he knows something
we don't know and there were early
interviews i thought why were they
scoffing oh he's an actor and he's
talking about the world coming to an end
so i
i was tuned in
a long time ago
but as it's become
increasingly obvious and now
everybody knows and now everybody should
be panicked like looking over the
shoulder when is it going to when is
this
apocalypse going to hit
i
i
i'm a different person because
what was theoretical
you know the the there are apar there
are buildings
uh apartment buildings in miami that i
uh but probably every a lot of other
places where they paid millions and
millions of dollars to have a sea of
view of the sea
right like right like on the sea and
their windows open up and they every
morning get up they go look at the sea
that's why they spent
20 million dollars for their for their
for their condo
villain yeah and they're erecting
20-foot walls now
to for the anticipation of the of higher
seas
there are cement walls going up blocking
their view
now how
how
dramatic is that guy pays all this money
for a view of the seat what well that's
global warming folks
yeah so that's happening now
and
and what i saw
was the vulnerability of this little
tiny
speck the stone this little rock kneel i
saw
i saw this
well the curvature about like that
but that's finite because you can go
continue the circumference and you come
to an end i've just described the
circumference of the earth
and you look out there the
you know i don't have to tell you
the em whole galaxies can come through
each other and not touch
billions of stars not hitting each other
because the space is so
vast between them
that
uh what is it coming our way uh
uh in two billion years uh what's the
name of the oh uh uh yeah you mean um
the andromeda galaxy uh drums again
and and
it's apparently possible for the whole
andromeda galaxy to come through the
milky way and not hit anything because
the space is so vast
correct
that's how vast space is
and this motive dust this little
i love the image
of this speck of sand this kernel of
this the grain of sand
in the sahara desert that's the volume
of this earth compared to uh space
and we
[Music]
are these little tiny you know we're
you can't describe us as ants because
we're we're smaller than ants compared
to
we're so fast we're tiny
yeah but the gasket is this where i
retrieve it is this way and i know you
know this
the miracle is us being able to
observe
to be a
party to
an observer of
this
miracle
of us being conscious enough
to be conscious of our
place in space and that to me is what
changed i understood this theoretically
but i saw it
and i am filled with that
thought that the miracle of human beings
looking and saying yes this is a speck
of dust yes we are a speck of dust on
the speck of dust
but we're observing it
we're we're
we're a party too an observer of the
grandeur
of it all the miracle of it all and the
miracle is inside us
and what is that i don't know what that
is i guess
consciousness
we were still trying to figure it out
but that was what i saw
many a philosopher have waxed poetic on
the fact that it's amazing that the
universe is knowable at all
you you know this
[Music]
moment
he's a colleague of mine
up at harvard
avi loeb has written this book on uh
using
moammoa
as the
chrysalis for the thoughts of
other civilizations existing whether
umuah is a
is a relic of some civilization or i
mean there's a great deal of argument
about it but he uses it and and
describes
scientific reason to think that it was
from uh another civilization somewhere
and just to catch everybody up
is a is an is an asteroid like object
interloper between the stars that
happened to pass through the solar
system in recent years and went around
the moon and made
uh
what's uh alleles in terms of its uh
trajectory it it changes
the trajectory was not entirely
newtonian as we say
and so the the the hunt was to find out
why and avi loeb was
um was more embracing of the possibility
that it could have been an alien craft
sent under its own power well not
therefore
he he came to the conclusion it must
have been like a sale like a a solar
sail
so we saw this part of it and thought it
was like a log
whereas in fact it was a dish that's
that's uh his theory but but you make
the good point that if you use that as
the as a launch point to even have that
conversation exactly that surely what he
does in his book he uses it as a
launching point to have the discussion
about
how dare we think because life is so
imperative
when you think that slime
seeks the sunlight
and and
mindless what we think of as mindless
things
trying to live
the imperative of life
i talked to bob ballard
who talked about seeing those chimneys
the calcified chimneys on 600 degrees
fahrenheit boiling water and 30 000 feet
depth
and
worms living and clams living life can
exist in the
extremophiles and
and so there's life
in other places as we as we surmise and
and the whole magic of it came alive for
me
in that trip
in that moment
well so what do you what do you
what do you want the future to hold
i can tell you this we surely agree
that star trek i think planted some
seeds
of what we want the future to be
and some tap roots have already taken
hold
but if we go 10 years 20 years should we
send every politician
uh forget the actors let's send the
politicians into space and then no you
don't lock them in a room in the u.n
afterwards
is it fungi or fungi
if you just
fungi is a is a west indian
dish made of cornmeal
fungi
fungi fungus and fungi you mean
mushrooms whatever
because i've heard it both ways
and i'm a little embarrassed to not know
what the correct pronunciation is
but there is a hole there the animal the
insect and and and and the
fungus
lying beneath we're just discovering
this whole other world
of fungus
yeah and there's an entire it's an
entire branch
of the entire sector of the tree of life
correct exactly and you and i are old
enough for it to have not been there
when we first learned of the tree of
life
people don't know this enough
people don't know this i like i love
mushrooms
and mushrooms are the fruit thereof and
and
but people don't know that there's a
whole there's so much going on on earth
and it's going to end
unless we do something now
about it not tomorrow not wait for funds
10 years from now we're on the cusp of
apocalypse you know that right
yes
yes
not not the apocalypse of our extinction
because i think we will survive some
humans will survive no matter what we're
on the brink of the loss of civilization
because all the greatest cities in the
world are on the water's edge and how
high can you build that 20-foot wall
right
before the ocean is just completely
overrun most of what we've taken 10 000
years to build exactly right back when
your first horses showed up further but
but then you go inland and you have the
extreme weather and you have the fires
and you have i mean
the the world as you and i know it
our children but especially our
children's children
are not going to know what we know and
see looking in your eyes right now
and seeing the pain like i don't want to
discuss this you're saying this is not
what i intended with shatner it is
a truth that we have to
impress upon
the person you meet on the street
bill give me a sense of hope you spent
three years on a tv show where every
single show
had
glimmers of hope so i embedded within it
i interviewed jeff bezos
okay
i don't know how much they showed on
this uh on this uh documentary but i had
intense conversations with mr bezos
whose
view is this let's get the polluting
industries
up into the air in orbit pollute up
there because it doesn't it'll dissipate
and get rid of the pollution here as
quickly as possible that's his that's
his drive
i said to him but jeff
that'll take a hundred years we don't
have a hundred years and he said i
propose what you just said
we have to have hope if without hope
what else is there
so the hope is
that all these warring politicians both
in our country and i'm canadian
and in the world
realize what you and i are talking about
the imperative what you and i are
talking about and the necessity of
immediate action
do we do that by sending them all into
space
well
in a hundred years if we're
still here and moving along
there will be a number of industries
people living in space coming down to
park like earth
for restoration
so why do you smile why do you why do
you smile you're one of the wisest and
most communicable of the of the of the
astral people
why do you smile strong
well
so okay so
uh by the way i think 100 years is a
very long time in the future when you
consider 100 years ago we were only just
swapping out cars with horses in the
cities so a lot can happen in 100 years
so let's hope it happens sooner than
that but
you're you're suggesting or implying
that
access to space will become so prevalent
that we can just send send
um politicians
and make decisions make a living up
there and come down here and find the
the earth with its natural beauty
yes that's the dream
so
because if we get a dream from anyone
it's got you know it's it's got it's got
to have star trek dna in it because it
was the only ones that well look
look at the look at this space the the
the the space vehicle uh people have
been living there for years now uh
coming out every six months coming back
down and then
by the international space station
yes so that's been there for many years
now amplify that
amplify that so that there's
industry going on they're burning coal
or oil if they have to making
electricity wiring it down here and and
because i don't want to use the word
beaming it down here and
you'd be totally forgiven for using the
word
okay we've eliminated a large source of
pollution
yes
yes unless everyone recycles everything
then there is no more pollution as a is
a what grandma used to have what's that
pollution
areas of the ocean with plastic in it
what grandma
[Laughter]
so bill we got to land this plane let me
just um remind people that it was the
the new shepherd
that was the capsule you went up with
launched by blue horizons a company
owned by jeff bezos and in the interest
of disclosure jeff bezos owns amazon and
owns prime where your documentary is
being shown right so
he's a remarkable man
he's a remarkable man remarkable the
dream and you want to use his fortune i
i i i learned to really care about him
what what i what i learned from the
documentary because we learned a little
bit about jeff bezos as well is that he
has very long
uh history dreaming about going into
space so this is not just some latter
day thought when you have some cash
falling out of your driving course
driving for us um i also wanted to
mention that i do a talk show uh called
uh i don't understand uh straight i was
a guest on your talk show thank you for
yes and you were yes wonderful guest and
it's all about things i don't understand
which is everything i hate to admit i
don't understand anything it was a
brilliant title
i enjoyed my my time there yes
and then there's this wonderful show
called the unexplained on um on the
history channel which is really great
fun it's very popular
well people love stuff that's not
explained what happens is sometimes they
jump too quickly to conclusions i can't
explain that it must have been aliens
who built it you know so i'm not that
quick to
i love the mystery but but i'm not so
quick to sort of invoke
uh an explanation william shatner thank
you for
lending us your time on star talk and
let's uh when you're 100 we'll bring you
back
and you'll get your 100-year perspective
on this world because you don't look
like you're going out anytime soon no i
hope not uh the i but i also want to say
how much i admire you and not only your
intelligence but your ability to
communicate it's very important i thank
you very much thank you thank you thank
you bill that's all the time we have got
to land this plane land the starship
uh thank you once again for being a
guest on star talk this not your first
rodeo with us
live long and prosper or rather live
longer
and be even more prosperous how's that
you already satisfied the first two
conditions
so we're out of here neil degrasse tyson
for star talk as always keep looking up
[Music]
and bill one last thing can i get you to
just ask me a question because we have
this series called celebrities ask neil
and then i answer that on online and
then then i won't i don't have to answer
it now but if we will have it
you say neil this has always been
neil why haven't all those vehicles on
mars discovered bacterial life
that's good do you have any others
we'll use that definitely
what is
going on in the interior of the moon
somehow when they leave everything
shakes
okay
you read too much you you
filling up the ash can